uh alex on the line from canberra um you
wanna have a little question about hbo
taking on the books
yeah hey uh nice to meet you george hi
there huge fan
i was just wondering if you have a say
to uh hbo's changes to the storyline
well i have a voice i mean i'm i write
one episode of season
i work with david and dan and you know
designing these things
but if they want to make a change that i
don't agree with i can try to persuade
them not to do it but i can't uh
you know veto it and of course hbo
writes to paychecks which uh
means they call the ultimate shots but i
knew that you did some changes are
inevitable you have to you have to
condense you have to combine characters
you can't
do a literal page by page scene by scene
line by line of dialogue of a of a novel
or a tv show
yeah well that makes perfect sense uh i
was just really gutted to uh find out
when
strong bellas was cut from the cast i'm
sorry about that
uh why did you particularly like belwas
he had that he had a swagger about him
he's probably
my favorite character in the in the
novel oh really oh well
that's he was i'm always fascinated to
hear things like that because of course
i have 314 characters and you know
strong below us is not the smartest guy
uh around there but you've got huddle
we have hodor yes uh who has massive
lines of dialogue but it's definitely
not a eunuch
uh hodor's ample equipment has been
commented on by several uh
several of the other characters in the
uh in the piece small of words
in other words i like bella myself i
would have liked they kept him
but he was one of the characters who uh
wound up on a cutting room floor
as did sadly i myself i did a cameo in
the original
uh scenes of danny's wedding but uh i
was cut
along with many other guests and i was
really a dashing figure too i was
i played a pentoshi merchant i had a
gigantic hat
and a set of big brass balls around my
neck oh no
and that was you could have been looking
now stan lee puts himself in every um
every movie made of his characters you
could have been that guy you could have
put yourself in
all of oh i know that's a shame i am in
i am in two episodes of beauty and the
beast
aficionados of that can go back in and
find me uh
are you wearing a hat that's a good
question i might have been wearing a hat
in one of those scenes but not in the
other hey alex thank you very much
steven
actually got someone on the phone now
who is a massive fan natalie's on the
line
from brisbane with a very simple
question this is possibly the top
comment
on facebook when we asked for questions
for you george natalie
hi there i'm just wondering if you're
going to stop killing off all the
characters that we love the most
well that depends on which characters
you love you know everybody has to be
loved
by somebody so all of the characters are
loved by somebody
but uh so i'm killing off characters as
somebody else does anyone love joffrey
really no
absolutely mother loves joffrey
come on everybody everybody gets loved
by their moms
no i actually really love varys because
i really love that whole machiavellian
vibe that he's got going on there it's
protecting the realm but really sort of
just manipulating everyone who's your
favorite natalie well
i don't want to use the incorrect tense
but it's probably jon snow
okay however i have just finished
reading a dance of dragons and along
with everyone else who's read it i'm
suffering from post-traumatic stress
i'm going to say i'm going to say
retrospective spoiler alert for like
five seconds alone
it goes well i don't think i gave it
away but
yeah i just need some sort of light at
the end of the tunnel can you tell me
did jamie lannister and our favorite
heroine brand of taft get together
i tell you nothing conceal all these
cards up my sleeve i knew it i wouldn't
have to have to keep reading to uh to
find out
i'm more than happy to keep reading i
will say that uh you know
some characters will make it through to
the end of the book so
that's about the most reassurance i can
give you what happens beyond the end of
the book of course you know all men must
die
i mean that's right in the books val or
mogulus so well as someone said the best
way to finish these up you know winter
is coming just have an ice age
then everyone bam gone well you know
that may be in the offing too we'll see
oh good i hope not i have a lovely one
natalie hey we're talking to george our
mum we haven't even mentioned red
wedding yet oh my gosh
oh yes the 8-bit game of thrones intro
for george r.r martin your
your dos computer could probably handle
this the one you typed the books on
it could be yeah it could be you've
really achieved such an amazing duality
people
love you and they hate you what people
were saying yesterday you ruined book
reading for them because after they get
to the end of the game of thrones
are the ice and fire books that's
they've got nothing else to read
nothing sort of comes close do you still
read fantasy i do
i still read many things i'm a fairly
voracious reader but
for one thing i get sent virtually every
fantasy is published anywhere in the
world now for
would you like to uh comment or give a
cover blurb to this fantasy
and uh and i do for some of them but i
love fantasy um
i love science fiction which is uh
something else i've written a lot of
horror stories but i also read a lot of
murder mysteries
i read a lot of history and historical
fiction
my unread shelf is just jammed with so
many books that uh
i could just do nothing but read people
would be stoked if you did that
people would be annoyed this is of
course when you started writing these
books
there wasn't these kind of massive
cinematic tv shows
which then your books could be turned
into like in the 90s i guess it was like
buffy and then that was before the
sopranos and lost and stuff really come
quite a long way
yeah we've we've uh television this is
the golden age of television i think
television has really
displaced feature films as where the
best drama
is being done there there used to be uh
in hollywood at least
a real pecking order they sort of look
down on television
but all of that's opened up now you have
people like martin scorsese directing uh
the first boardwalk empire and you know
major
major feature film directors being
involved major actors
did it feel weird handing over um your
books your baby your babies your many
babies
to hbo yeah a little bit i mean it it is
uh
it is like your babies and you know you
have your children and yeah comes a time
when you have to send your children off
to school and entrust them to people and
the people you're entrusting them to
seem nice but you never know
uh there's always a certain trepidation
well what if they're really
you know cannibals or something like
that